hello and welcome to this video playing
ich spy
let's see what happens it could be
translated to me too
it's probably a german account but i
don't think there's a name in there i
know we played before it
okay so we have a modern defense or
yeah probably modern defenses the right
way to call that
d5 i guess you usually want to play d5
before they play d5
it's a bit unusual this position
i know bishop takes c3
would be a very of a guard way to play
it
okay pawn takes it seems like he does
not want to take on c3
maybe queen b3 coming at some point
okay let's continue
knight f5 is something that maybe
is honey it is on my wow is on his
agenda
whoop so yeah i'm not worried that he
takes a pawn
that should be far too risky here you
know
and now bishop g5
yeah well h6 is probably not too bad
queen b3 queen b6 i can also just take
of course and be a little bit better
yeah maybe take some pragmatic way to do
it
all right now how do we play it
it's maybe going to play d5
i wonder what i do with this bishop if i
should play something like
bishop f4 or bishop g5
okay this is probably useful in any case
d4 knight e4
yeah maybe this is going to be
good to create a weakness
okay bishop f4
um
i have to be careful a little bit like
something like
queen d2 for example g5
i'm not quite sure what i'm doing then
bishop e3 there's d4
that looks um
quite annoying is that possible
all right that is some bit of a problem
b2 is hanging but ok rook b1 and then
what
oh interesting isn't bishop c7 not
winning the queen now
there's just no square right
i didn't see that beforehand but it's
it's possible
yeah i only saw knight c7 not that
bishop c7 is an additional threat
it was a fun way to quickly end the game
i mean let's have a look this is um
known variation
g3 and
yeah takes the double pawn is not a big
problem we
always have f4 later if possible or if
necessary is the right word
to activate the bishop and the half open
e file is generally useful so e6
d5 is how you normally play this not the
only way to do it but it's possible
pawn takes 97 yeah bishop h3 is just
yeah well computer wants to do it as
well but i mean it makes sense yeah
knight f5 should be prevented
if possible c6 and i see no reason to in
north castle
um he cannot i believe grab this pawn
this is not going to work right
yeah it's just too much um they were pro
here they are probably funny
checkmates here yeah yeah this is one
nice so we castled i took on c6 okay
this is not liked by the engine m
kind of believable i'm
resolving the tension i just wanted to
have a simple
move and this is why i played it bishop
f4 bishop g5 looks better
so develops rookie one i mean i'm still
quite okay here
so bishop f4 and yeah this is already
losing knight b5
yeah i mean this is really bishop c7 on
top
of everything is awful i just saw that
knight c7 is
almost impossible to stop but bishop c7
is of course a much more severe issue
amazing
he just loses the exchange the engine
wants to play like d4
knight c7 bishop c7
now there is oops this one there is
queen d5 so that's not the good but
knight c7 wins the exchange
yeah remarkable how quickly that went
downhill
i mean it's a good position for white
but not as good
as winning on move 16. okay guys thanks
for watching